there's a lot of noise in the landscape
for financial services right now we're
seeing a confluence of competitive
pressures coming from different places
how should companies think about how
they can either preserve strengthen or
build their own competitive modes in
this changing landscape FinTech
navigating that's evolving competitive
and regulatory landscapes is really
about how fintechs banks and regulators
can systematically think about the
changing competitive environment and how
to design and respond to regulations in
this changing world be it issues related
to big data and algorithms competitive
strategy digital currencies and crypto
currencies in the payment system we've
brought together a group of faculty who
have fought conceptually deeply about
the theoretical underpinnings and roles
of these different dimensions of the
financial services industry and at the
same time have an enormous amount of
business experience practical experience
working with companies to resolve
specific problems the practitioners the
participants in these programs and the
faculty spend an enormous Lee fruitful
week understanding how to prioritize
understanding how to cut through the
noise and see what the clear underlying
fundamental issues are and to begin to
frame solutions to the problems that
they're facing within their own
businesses
their own challenge in designing
regulation to move the industry forward
we're going to be drawing broadly upon
the strengths of Stanford in terms of
its human capital but also our style and
location here in terms of the
entrepreneurial spirit this diversity of
perspectives and human capital will all
be in the room together challenging each
other appreciating each other's
challenges working together to begin to
see how to develop frameworks that they
can take back and share more broadly
within their own companies there's such
an opportunity right now to bring
greater clarity to these cross currents
of economic pressures and changing
regulations and who are going to be the
winners who are going to be the losers
this is a perfect environment to take up
these issues to challenge ourselves and
there's just a fantastic group of
faculty stirring it all